su primera cita frente al parlamento
como primera ministra de reino unido
[Aplausos]
me siento honrada de ocupar mi lugar
como primera ministra en esta cámara y
asumir la responsabilidad en un momento
vital para nuestro país
me atendió las preguntas de los
diputados entre los temas clave que dan
luz sobre lo que será su gobierno está
la política internacional y lo que será
su relación con la unión europea
afectadas de la salida de reino unido
del bloque comunitario
necesitamos resolver el problema del
protocolo de irlanda del norte mi
preferencia es una solución negociada
pero tiene que ofrecer todas las cosas
que establecimos en el protocolo de
irlanda del norte- rights golpeó otro
tema vital para los británicos es cómo
enfrentar la crisis energética los
costos de la factura de energía y el
alto costo de vida medios locales
señalan que trozos estaría considerando
un paquete de 115 mil millones de
dólares para ayudar con el aumento del
costo de vida incluido el apoyo para
pagar las facturas de energía
tomaré medidas inmediatas para ayudar a
las personas con el costo de sus
facturas de energía y haré un anuncio a
esta cámara sobre este tema mañana de
house o más
pero el líder opositor del partido
laborista que starmer criticó a la nueva
premier
bueno espero con ansias la declaración
de mañana pero el dinero tiene que venir
de alguna parte y ella sabe que cada
libra de exceso de ganancias que decide
no gravar es una libra extra de
préstamos que los trabajadores se verán
obligados a devolver
a pocos meses de la llegada del invierno
reino unido tendrá que afrontar desafíos
gigantes en temas sociales y económicos
al mando de quien la prensa ya considera
como la nueva dama de hierro
[Aplausos]